McDonald's they're cutting the healthy
stuff the famous fruit & walnut salad a
bunch of their chicken selects and even
some of their angus things are gonna
disappear what do we do if McDonald's
can't keep us healthy people there's a
chance that's been no being debated
that's all but that's not know but it's
like a higher cut of meat Thomas you
know what I mean the salad is the
healthy part two pieces of lettuce does
not a salad make if you can't get your
cheap salad at McDonald's you're just
going down the end of on health it
shocks me that they wouldn't just keep
the apples on the menu which show
because they know they're gonna be
criticized yeah for the thousand Li
calorie burger regardless of whether
people are eating it just put it up
there and try to make an effort show
that you're trying yeah even fake apples
would be fine for them just like a horse
you can't afford to pick one up horse
meat is in basically everything I light
now battle yeah cuz I'm an animal um
yeah it's delicious Sevilla pedalboard
sweet a good idea fact i justjust that
ikea the other day I saw off me well I
saw you know people love that stuff that
I yeah and there were a ton of people
feeding their kids and it's like here
there be a suit or something for horse
meeting you guys just chowing down on
the horse meat it's just we just love is
that just how it is Americans we just
love kind of the the crap we just love
this crappy stuff well they clearly
don't trust the media that's that's part
of the ninety-four percent that don't
trust the media remember that's telling
them to eat healthier not that meaty
that's telling that the meatballs are
made of horse meat yeah I'm by oh they
don't even buy that they don't even buy
that they're like media they're tricking
us but um mcdonnell's I boycotted
McDonald's I haven't been going for
several years now and this is why and I
feel like I'm gonna get it out yes it's
something I've been keeping in for a
while the only thing I ever get at
mcdonalds is a diet coke and an ice
cream cone have you ever waited 20
minutes on a drive-thru line only to get
up there for them to tell you
ice cream machine is broken now that's
terrible it's happened to me for five
times four or five toilet and there's
nothing you can do they need to put a
sign wait when you get to the
drive-through no ice cream today i have
to say i actually have stopped going to
mcdonalds dave despite what you said I
stopped doing it because it actually has
like the Passover effect on me where it
just stops me up and I know what I'm
talking about are there any you're
jewish yeah you know where your
counselor again it is soaked up like
physically stopped up you can't poop Oh
what I'm saying to you is it had more so
than any other garbage that you can eat
it like it's literally you're putting
like styrofoam I look like either a
boycott McDonald's like it was Noble
yeah I mean like you didn't know I mean
over i scryed appreciate that you said
like you boycotted McDonough's and I
thought oh god what did they did a part
I like what is it what is it it was like
ice cream it was I see if you know what
here we've our big partners ice cream
played in my life you would understand I
respect that you are the way you are the
parts what about the bonobos calm is the
official outfitter of the Ruben report
enter code Ruben report for twenty
percent off your next purchase